[Music]
kathy's in buffalo new york hi kathy
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hi um i'm a senior in college and
unfortunately i mean i work pretty hard
throughout college to like save up money
for a car and just like an apartment
after graduation and just for food and
living expenses
um and i had around like 25 000 saved up
for my car and just like after
graduation but unfortunately covid kind
of hit my family hard and my uncle had
to borrow money to pay for my grandpa's
hospital bill i'm like my grandpa and my
dad
um and now like they're not really
giving my money back if that makes sense
and i don't really know what to do about
it
how old are you
um 21
how old your uncle
oh
i mean i i don't know but probably 40
45. so this 45 year old comes to the 21
year old college kid and says i can't
pay my dad's hospital bill you need to
help
and you gave them your mother
yeah yeah your family's a bunch of
irresponsible people aren't they
um yeah they're broke and they can't
take care of their grandpa and they come
to a kid to take care of them that's the
definition of irresponsible i'll help
you with that i shouldn't have been a
question should have been a statement
okay
how much money did you give them
um i mean because like you know hospital
bills are like extraordinarily expensive
like fifteen thousand good lord
so you give him fifteen thousand dollars
and what was the term what was the plan
for him to repay you
um
like i said within like the next year
yeah and he said okay
yeah where was he gonna get the money
um the thing was like my aunt was out of
work um just because like she lost her
job and then she was going to pay me
back like when she got a job where's
your parents
um my parents like my parents like my
dad's kind of arguing with my brother i
mean with his brother but like they kind
of the two of them are like having their
own fight about money issues
that's shocking
oh kiddo i'm so sorry you are in a mess
i just want to box your uncle's
and
ears
wish you had i wish you had stood up and
just said no don't you
yeah i just didn't want like you know my
grandpa they're not going to repossess
your grandpa it's just a hospital bill
they'll sue somebody for not paying a
hospital bill
but they're not going to repossess him
yeah you got you got snookered by your
family
yeah your next time your family knocks
on the door you need to just not open
the door
oh my gosh how long ago was this kathy
um this happened like
maybe a year and a half
i guess like yeah like a year and a half
ago at the beginning of 2020. do you
have anything in writing from your uncle
um yeah i have like an email
um
okay
well um
it doesn't sound like your father is
gonna be any help because he's not uh
got influence with your uncle right now
because they're already fighting am i
correct
yeah cause like again so if you call
your uncle and say all right look
this is a mess and i've you're gonna
this is gonna cost me going to college
you've got to get this money together go
to the bank and get it
and send me my money i've got to have
this money what's he going to say
i mean i tried doing that and then like
um because like the thing is like i
tried doing that and you're just like
you can go into debt i'll pay you back
my promise and like because of that
because like that was also supposed to
be like harsh because like i pay like 10
grand a year for school because of like
financial aid and then like food and
rent on top of that and then it's just
kind of like i kind of have to hold my
tuition though
um
because of that what a butthole am i
going to do
this guy's a class a
yeah
i'm sorry
um i i i don't know how to make a person
that doesn't have character suddenly
have character and your your uncle is a
scumburger
and you realize that now
yeah i like i knew that but i mean i
didn't know going into the situation
because he wasn't you know i mean i
never like your parents never really
dealt with him financially sad the bad
news is at 21 years old you've had this
very harsh lesson
the great news is you will never have to
have this lesson again because you will
never do something like this again
because this is hurt so badly and put
you in such a bad position
and so the you know i i hope you haven't
lost the money permanently but you
probably have because your uncle was
scum
yeah
anybody that would come to a 21 year old
and ask for their college money
in order to take care of their
grandfather because you didn't go figure
out some other way to do it is scum by
definition
by definition because if the worst case
scenario is grandpa let me tell you if
he'd call me i just said grandpa can't
pay his bill call the hospital tell him
he can't pay the bill he didn't have any
money
i'd rather owe the hospital money than i
would little kathy
that it's just a matter who we're going
to owe
right
this is just this is just garbage it's
just garbage oh my gosh kathy
so here's the thing
i you have really two courses of action
and none of them are good
i wish i could give you a good answer
course of action number one is calling
back and say
um
i sure hope you can pay me i sure hope
you do what you said you were going to
do i hope you're a man of honor and a
man of your word because you're leaving
me in a lurch
and hang up the phone
and then have low expectations because
he's scum that you ever get this money
and you're probably not going to get it
okay
uh course of action number two is higher
lawyer and sue is but
yeah i'm kind of too broke for that i
mean
they'll take it because this looks like
fun
i'm telling you they'll take it for a
percentage and when he collects it out
of your uncle's hide
he'll um
you know but here's the thing you'll be
done with him forever but by the way if
he's my uncle i'm done with him forever
anyway
he's not gonna speak to you again once
you sue him but i really don't care
because he ain't worth speaking to this
guy's a dirt bag
kathy he treated you like a doormat
because you're a really nice sweet
person and he thought he could get the
money took advantage of a 21 year old
young lady in college
this is making me mad as your adopted
uncle
i'm your other uncle the one that's
gonna kill this one
[Laughter]
yeah it's like really bad because it's
like all of my like all of my other
uncles are like hating this one uncle
and like my mom's dad's also like really
pissed off it's like yeah you got a mess
on your dysfunctional it's not fair that
you have to deal with this
so you have two choices
just lower your expectations and don't
expect to get the money or go whole hog
and start the wrong grenades with an
attorney
that's your two choices make your
decision and then rest in peace
with whichever decision you rest in
either one's fine with me and either one
will be great i'm so sorry george one of
the things we've discovered in uh
studying family businesses is that the
family business is never
any more
or less toxic than the family it's never
any more less functional or more
functional than the family is a
dysfunctional family cannot have a
functional
family business
the other thing that kind of goes with
that the
parallel track for that is
there there's a a lot of data in our
data here over 30 years of doing this
and and even in the millionaire research
that indicates that
to the extent that
your immediate family husband and wife
and your extended family uncles
aunts
parents
so on
to the extent that
people observe
correct and reasonable
moral
boundaries with each other to the extent
that the marriage is functional to the
extent that the
interaction with the grown kids
and grandkids is functional
meaning that there's not a bunch of
manipulation lying drug use
uh
cheating whatever running around on it
whatever all this stuff to the extent
they're functional there's a high
correlation with that and the ability to
build wealth there's a high correlation
you can't build wealth in the middle of
if you're if your family just puts the
fun in dysfunction i mean it's just very
difficult to do it it's kind of been the
theme this hour yeah
a lot of dysfunction on all these calls
and what it comes down to is you can't
give family money it just never ends up
working out for you i'd rather you be
mad at a lender and sally may and sally
may sue you than a family member sue you
because that relationship is done
it's hard to recover but you when you
have a money problem
of any kind in the family but husband
and wife buying a van
you have a money problem
in the family
uncle wants money to pay grandpa's
medical bills when you have a money
problem in the family it is never the
problem
it is always the symptom
of something else going on yeah and so
the very fact that this family system in
that last call is set up in a way that a
40-something year old man can call a
21-year-old
niece
who's in college and basically steal her
college fund
and in his mind somehow that's all right
or it didn't happen this hour but we've
gotten the call before
you know these parents who
take their minor children's identity and
go open a bunch of credit cards in them
and then when the minor children gets
married
as an adult and is 25 26 years old
discovers that there's a whole bunch of
credit card debt that their mom put in
their name when they were 14.
i mean
that's just that's that's criminal fraud
go to jail do not pass go
but people do it
and there's this this thing that happens
in some of our families out there
that people make this statement
well you have to take care of family
as if that statement makes all of your
miscellaneous ridiculousness
go away
like well i i just can't i have to take
care of mama i have to i mean you have
to you have to take care of family you
just have to take care of him whatever
it is i mean i mean yeah i understand he
stole three cars he does cocaine he shot
his neighbor but you have to take care
of family you know but you know i mean
people are just ridiculous at what point
does it just become enabling misbehavior
yeah i think mom didn't save up any
money her whole life and now it's our
job to take care of her for the next 20
years and that's not mean okay it's if
you want to take care of mom and you're
able to take care of mom
that's okay but this idea that you take
this child's
fund
i just want to
send out the ramsey swat team for this
guy man doesn't exist by the way america
in case you're wondering oh we could we
could form it pretty quick around here
though that's right
but that that's
just makes you furious to hear stories
like that so here's the thing guys my
point of this rant is
that if you do not recognize where crazy
is in your family and every family is
crazy in it and if you think yours
doesn't it's you
so um if you ever if you don't recognize
where crazy is in your family and learn
to put proper boundaries in place
early
in your life
and you don't teach you know let's say
you got a
functional family mom and dad are
teaching a 14 year old who later becomes
a 21 year old okay uncle someone says
bad news okay he comes around just blow
him off stranger danger okay danger
danger that's right stranger dog
kindergarten copper there we go good
yeah but i mean
you gotta it's yeah you have to teach
the danger of this and it it's just oh
man everyone needs to read that henry
clown until you fix your marriage you're
not gonna build wealth until you set
boundaries with your crazy uncle and
your your deadbeat drug son you're not
gonna build wealth until you deal with
the dysfunction in your family you're
not gonna build wealth you can't get
rich enough to not screw it up with
these people intersecting your life and
you just allowing them free reign
because they're just gonna take care of
family you know that kind of cr it's
just ah
do people think that they're they're
being selfish if they don't help is that
what it comes down to it's it's enabling
from now on and and these people the
people on the other side of it are their
travel agents for guilt trips oh that's
good i mean this guy he just well
grandpa you got to kill your grandpa
your poor old grandpa don't you take
care of your grandpa you're selfish
little college student aren't you well
it made me smack you
unbelievable how did we know he even
used that on medical bills now i'm
second guessing this guy's integrity
going who knows what that money went
towards
there's a car in the driveway probably
no it's a pickup
always a pickup isn't it it's always a
bass boat
uh wouldn't be a ski boat it'd be a
basketball
you've got the ski boat that's why
you're saying that ski boat folk are
different
no they're not they're just as bad oh my
gosh i'm telling this is just but here's
the thing
you can't outrun this
you have to deal with the family stuff
or you're not going to get ahead
financially you're always going to be
brought down
by the dysfunction until you've dealt
with the dysfunction or put a boundary
to the dysfunction and a fence around
you to where you can work around it
you're not you you cannot make enough
money to out earn this
you have to deal with it so there's a
high correlation
between the ability to build wealth and
good boundaries and functional families
my grandmother used to say
when she was alive she's in a small town
she would say so-and-so comes from a
good family
now
certain members of our family would
accuse her of being uppity like she
thought they meant that meant that they
were country club folk or something
instead of the other kind of folk right
and that wasn't what she was referring
to at all when i got to know her as an
adult later what she meant was
they were a good family they had
integrity that's what she meant
and you want to you want you want to be
around a good family and there are good
families there none of them are perfect
but i mean there are some that do a
better job at this stuff than others but
oh my gosh it's almost impossible
to you know some of you have to just
become a some of you are listening in
your 19 or 21 you just have to become an
adult and set up your own life because
your whole bunch over there's nuts
you know and you just got to come over
here to the side and just look over
there and like they're like they're like
something in a psychology book every one
of them's got one of those things you
know i mean it's like unbelievable
and so you some of you just have to do
that and some of you just have to deal
with the one crazy mother-in-law
you know and some of you have to deal
with your marriage stuff and not be so
dadgum selfish and power-hungry and
entitled and all those things which
sharon and i have dealt with coming up
on 40 years
and uh now i've kind of got it down with
sharon though i have figured it out
george what's the secret i told her the
other day if she leaves i'm going with
her
how'd she take it
she might put out a restraining order at
that point
man don't give her ideas
she's thought of it i have her convinced
i'm not i'm no genius i have her
convinced well here's what it comes down
to
you've got to have boundaries and you
can't change people and so at some point
you've gotta just draw the line and say
listen uncle he's just cut off we just
can't be friends with uncle you can't be
friends with grandma because it's toxic
and that's a hard thing to do today
about the money it's about the fact that
you stole from me
yes you know
it's not the money the money doesn't
matter
it's that you
mistreated a 21 year old college student
you jerk
you unbelievable jerk
i hope he's listening i hope he i hope i
get that email back that'll be a fun one
hey unk if you're listening jump on i'd
love to talk to you that'll be fun
not for you